[Music]
[Applause]
uh he's the cincinnati head coach in his
sixth year luke fickle and uh he was at
ohio state for his playing career
coaching career but he's turned that
cincinnati program around they certainly
did some damage last year got a couple
players in the pros desmond ritter with
the falcons sauce gardner with the jets
cincinnati plays at number 19 arkansas
on saturday at 3 30 eastern and coach
joins us now you're not going to be able
to sneak up on anybody this year right
i don't think so um which is a good
thing you know i mean i think in those
those second and third years we we still
were trying to you know make sure people
understood who we were and and you know
make a name for ourselves and you know i
think there's you put an evolution to
what it is that you're doing and uh you
know i don't think by now that uh
they're gonna sneak up on a whole lot
but that win in notre dame and in south
bend that
got people's attention because that felt
like okay this is a true big did it feel
like it was a turning point changing
perception point for you
well we always said that you know until
you beat one of those blue bloods you
know it's hard to be lumped into or even
given the respect and uh you know
to happen at any point in time but
you've seen it all over years and years
but i think the consistency and then to
win that game especially on the road um
gave us a little more validity for even
what we were doing as a program because
you know when we got beat by george or
whatever it was like hey we're not to
where we need to be we know we got to
grow and until you complete beat one of
those top five type 10 you know
historically national teams um you know
you don't have a whole lot to
hang your hat on
yeah and and i don't know what it does
for future scheduling you got arkansas
right out of the gate that's a you know
top 20 team
when was that game scheduled
i'm not sure i'm sure it was probably
four or five years ago um you know i was
one of those guys never looked very far
ahead you know so i i until about two
years ago i when they said it let's talk
schedules i was like what does it matter
you know i mean we've got a long way to
go let's we're just going to keep our
eyes here and do this and
you know until about two years ago okay
i maybe have a few minutes here to try
to think about some of that stuff and
then look at the future and planning for
yours for your program but uh that was
probably about five years out um i think
it is unique i think it's unique to to
go down south to start against an scc
team you never know what kind of team
you're having five years away whether
it's your own team or their team um but
i always think it's going to be an
environment no matter what um that you
got to be prepared for but i wonder are
you going to be able to schedule
opponents that will help you be in the
playoff now that you guys are good and
that you're in a conference
i don't i don't know where we're headed
here luke
i don't either and and i know that i
would say that you know we're in the big
12. um i don't know that you got to go
out and make sure you've got a marquee
game you know i'm not saying you avoid
them but i think that uh when you're in
those leagues you got to say that our
league is strong enough that it's going
to put us in a position no matter what
it is that we do if we win um but i i
still think there's a push in college
football
in some way somehow if we grow this you
know playoff system i'm not getting all
that you know soapbox name of sorts but
it'll give us more opportunities through
the whole country to play some of these
games earlier in the year we get no
preseason we get no scrimmage
you know so the first one is always
really tough but i think if it doesn't
you know completely you know have a
overriding impact on the entire season
um i think we'll see a lot more of these
games but did you know what was the
difference you noticed between your team
and georgia
i think it comes down it's just natural
size i think the guys up front is where
you first see it um you know and i'm not
saying we don't have big guys but
sometimes our guys are in their fourth
and fifth year you know that have kind
of grown in to be a 310 pounder where
you know i think sometimes in the sec
and some of the leagues you get guys
walking the door that are naturally 310
pounds and there are sometimes a little
bit of a size difference
and i think it's more up front i think
you know a lot of the skill positions
and things like that well that defensive
line was pretty impressive that georgia
had
well yeah i i've watched them on film
again this year just getting prepared
for this game and it's a hard one to
watch because you're like i don't know
if we can do some of those things um but
i think i think with the top five ten
teams that's where the difference
usually comes it's those guys up front
we're talking to luke fickle he's the
cincinnati head coach they have arkansas
at arkansas and they're the 19th ranked
team in the country coming up this
saturday how many of your players know
that you played
nose guard
uh well i would say a few i'm not sure
as many as the younger kids i think when
when it first started you taught me i
not you talked about it but even you
know i as the as the you know you
changed you became the new head coach i
think there's a lot more talk about
where you came from
once you've been there for a few years i
think you've been able to change the
talk to what it is that we've done as
coaches um but there's times when i do
remind them that hey this is a this is
an old defensive lineman wrestler so i
just don't want you guys to forget that
yeah but you ever get into a stance do
you ever get down you know all fours
just to tell them show them how it's
done
yeah you know i i try to and then try to
stop
short of making contact because i'm not
sure exactly what will happen i'm not
sure if the achilles will will continue
to stay intact or what it is so you know
you can you can fool them with a stance
and an alignment and you know some
intensity in your face
i'm not sure i want to want to show them
how to come off the ball and what it
looks like when you when contact is made
is cincinnati in a position where
you
lose players to the portal or are you
getting players from the portal
we've been very very very fortunate
we've lost a few
not many that we would say i don't want
that to happen
um we've lost two young guys i think in
the last couple years that just never
quite give themselves an opportunity
to understand and embrace the culture
so for us even when the portal first
started i said this is going to be an
advantage to us
because we're going to take care of our
kids we're going to relationship with
our kids so they won't leave but then
we're going to have opportunities to
bring the right ones into our program
whether they're younger or older guys
just to give us you know
you know some difference makers or some
variety it's not the way we want to
build the program or grow the program
but it's a way that we can enhance the
program
good luck against arkansas coach thanks
for joining us
appreciate thanks for having me that's
luke fickle cincinnati head coach they
got arkansas number 19
this year
that'll be this weekend